[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans face
aux territoires sur tv5monde en direct
avec nos co producteur diffusée sur
ouest france.fr sur nicematin.com et sur
franceantilles.fr avec le léger décalage
horaire du au fuseau horaire cette
émission est réalisée également en
partenariat avec le journal 20 minutes
aujourd'hui notre invité c'est sophie
cluzel bonjour bonjour vous êtes là
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées depuis 2010 est demain le 3
décembre c'est la journée internationale
des personnes handicapées c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous êtes présente
sur ce plateau en direct merci et
vendredi et le cas des cendres c'est le
téléthon également il faut le rappeler
qu'ils sont deux événements très
importants dans la vie de votre
ministère on en parlera tout à l'heure
l'actualité c'est la cour suprême des
etats-unis qui pourrait restreindre
sophie cluzel le droit à l'avortement
sont neuf juges dont six qui sont
conservateurs qui ont examiné une loi du
mississippi interdisant d'avorter après
quinze semaines de grossesse comment
vous expliquez que dans la plus grande
démocratie du monde et au moment de me
tout moment de ce set ce mouvement de
libération des femmes dans le monde
entier on puisse avoir ce genre de
nouvelles dans la nuit c'est très
inquiétant c'est très inquiétant parce
que c'est une remise en cause de liberté
qui ont été acquises par les femmes pour
les femmes et je pense qu'il faut il
faut en être vigilant ces libertés il
faut les défendre tout le temps on voit
qu'elles peuvent être remises en cause
et non non c'est très inquiétant parce
que ce sont une une cour une cour
suprême peut être très conservatrice
peut-être aussi avec des profils qui
sont pas très jeune et qui ne
comprennent pas que l'importance c'est
d'écouter des avancées sociétales qui
ont été faites et donc ça je pense qu'il
faut vraiment préserver nos libertés
tout le temps donc on va suivre cette
actualité aux états unis donc elle
pourrait restreindre le non à
l'avortement ça n'est évidemment pas
acquis
françoise et guy lefrand rédacteur en
chef de ouest france nous revenons un
instant sur ses plateaux
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier le franc bonjour
sur le plateau voilà merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sophie cluzel est notre
invité secrétaire d'état chargé des
personnes handicapées nous allons
démarrer avec didier de abreu qui est
coordinateur sécurité routière en
ille-et-vilaine un département que vous
connaissez bien françois xavier le
francky père d'une jeune fille autiste
qui s'appelle fleurs vous allez le voir
il a une question à vous poser sophie
cluzel bruno chiroux l'a rencontré pour
essence
bonjour madame la secrétaire d'état il
s'avère que beaucoup de personnes en
situation de handicap sont laissés sur
le bord du chemin et notamment les
jeunes de entre 18 et 24 ans alors ils
sortent du milieu scolaire où finissent
leur cursus à ni à me et se retrouve
sans rien
sans solution mais surtout avec un
nouveau combat demain eux avec leur
famille pour préparer leur avenir alors
certes des initiatives des dispositifs
ont été mis en place par le gouvernement
mais beaucoup restent en dehors de ces
dispositifs et surtout dans l'angle mort
des institutions alors madame la
secrétaire d'état comment pensez vous
les trouvez ces jeunes et les aider à
être acceptés dans notre société merci
madame
eh bien je voudrais répondre au papa de
fleurs que ces jeunes c'est 16 25 ans
mamie font l'objet de toutes nos
attentions accord en situation
d'handicap a dans l'ensemble du
gouvernement un jeune une solution c'est
bien ça donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait faut
qu'on ait une continuité
d'abord en valeur simplifier la vie
parce que moi je veut automatiser tout
simplement la reconnaissance de qualité
de travailleur handicapé quand on a été
jeune plus besoin de refaire son dossier
c'est ce que je porte dans la loi 3ds
qui va bientôt passer faut qu'on arrête
de vous harceler administrativement de
reprieve est votre situation de handicap
ce qui a été fait sur l'école ce que
l'on veut c'est une continuité de
parcours c'est pour ça que par exemple
dans les centres de formation
d'apprentis les 960 on a mis un référent
handicap pour prendre en compte les
spécificités et puis c'est aussi tout ce
que l'on développe sur l'emploi
accompagner le job coaching surtout pour
les autistes c'est exactement fait pour
eux partout sur les territoires des
plates formes d'emploi accompagnés
gratuit pour les entreprises gratuit
pour les personnes qui vont accompagner
le projet professionnel pour ouvrir la
porte de l'entrée
évidemment le capital ce qu'on oublie
parfois aussi quand on connaît mal le
sujet c'est que ce sont des jeunes qui
peuvent se retrouver du jour au
lendemain sans relation coupé de
relations amicales de relations
régulières qu'ils avaient et qui peuvent
être extrêmement déstabilisé s'il n'y a
pas de structures d'accueil pour les
pour les recevoir alors c'est tout
l'enjeu de l'accompagnement
l'accompagnement de ces jeunes
l'accompagnement de leurs familles c'est
bien pour ça que ce job coaching était
là pour justement ne pas couper ses
relations et puis on développe les
services d'accompagnement il n'y a pas
de limite d'âge pour être accompagné ses
pas vingt ans que ça s'arrête on peut
pousser les murs vraiment d
accompagnement parce que ce que je veux
éviter c'est ce que le papa de fleurs
nous dit la rupture de solutions et
c'est ça qu'on l'on veut vraiment éviter
comment ils et les parents qui sont
confrontés à des montagnes de problèmes
qui peuvent se retrouver aussi très
isolés c'est très perturbant très très
très inquiétant très douloureux souvent
quand on voit son enfant qui a pas de
structures d'accueil comment aider les
parents
psychologiquement également alors deux
choses d'abord un parent ne restent pas
seuls on a un tissu associatif
extraordinaire en france et je le
connais bien j'en suis issu donc
vraiment là les associations notamment
sur l'autisme font un travail
remarquable d'accompagnement ne restez
pas seul deuxièmement les maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées qui sont sous la
responsabilité des présidents de
département travaille justement à cet
accompagnement et troisièmement ce que
l'on met en place et les communautés 360
et donc il ya un numéro le 0 800 363 160
pour éviter justement l'isolément avoir
ces ruptures et en fait créé du sur
handicap sur un handicap social parce
qu'il ya plus cette interaction et puis
surtout il nous faut absolument éviter
la rupture de prise en charge ça c'est
très important alors il se trouve que le
fleurs donc cette jeune fille dont on a
entendu le papa tout à l'heure elle
c'est une artiste elle elle dessine elle
fait des choses superbes et ça mène à
vous poser une question sur la quai sur
la autour de la culture comment aider
comment favoriser
l'implication des handicapés dans le
monde culturel comment les aider à
participer à des événements culturels
comment les aider peut-être aussi à
exposer eux mêmes comment créer ce lien
dans le dans le monde de la culture et
on voit les dessins de fleurs derrière
vous sophie cluzel très bien alors
fleurs j'invite à rejoindre justement
tous les réseaux associatifs puisque
j'étais la marraine de la biennale art
et handicap mental très récemment et on
veut développer cela vraiment donner la
parole deux choses la personne
handicapée faut qu'elles aient accès
comme tout un chacun déjà à la
connaissance de la culture c'est pour ça
avec lui qu'on a développé le pass
culture partout avec avec la ministre de
la culture roselyne bachelot puisqu'on a
créé vraiment le comité de pilotage
injustement de pour travailler sur
l'accès à la culture l'accès à la
culture ça veut dire faire des par
exemple des des expositions qui sont
accompagnés pour le handicap bien sûr
mental psychique la formation il ya un
réseau qui s'appelle leur écart le
réseau ad des musées qui travaille
énormément et je salue vraiment j'étais
pas plus tard que il ya un mois avec
catherine pégard au château de
versailles qui a mis en place des
ateliers extrêmement pointus pour les
personnes polyhandicapées parce que
justement ces sens extrêmement développé
chez les personnes qui n'ont pas la
communication doivent pouvoir être
exacerbée et puis surtout pratiques et
donc ça c'est très important et ouvrir
bien sûr toutes les événements les les
expositions à l'ensemble des personnes
handicapées mais sauf je salue le
travail de ce love qui est assez
remarquable cerveau ils sont beaux ces
dessins c'est sa fille cluzel parce
qu'internet a chargé des personnes
handicapées qu'est notre invité ce matin
sur tv5 monde d'en face aux territoires
syrie goutier qui le directeur éditorial
de france-antilles notre partenaire
également une question à vous poser
madame la ministre on écoute
bonjour la ministre personnes en
situation de handicap appel plusieurs
questions dans les outre mer la première
c'est celle de la détection de certains
handicaps je pense particulièrement à
l'autisme où il n'est pas toujours
évident de poser rapidement un
diagnostic
la seconde c'est plus celle de
l'accessibilité même si différents plans
ont été mises en oeuvre on m'accuse
toujours notamment aux antilles un
certain retard par rapport à la
situation en métropole
je pense notamment à l'accessibilité
dans les villes
de nos territoires quelles sont les
mesures sur lesquelles vous travaillez
et qui pourrait améliorer
d'une part la prise en charge d'autres
par l'accessibilité
alors oui il faut intervenir précocément
c'est le maître mot pour l'autisme c'est
pour ça que dans la stratégie nationale
pour l'autisme nous avons mis en place
des plateformes de coordination pour
repérer très tôt pendant trop longtemps
on a culpabilisé les familles notamment
les maires en disant vous avez le temps
c'est pas grave et c'est là non on agit
très précocement avec aucun reste à
charge pour les familles puisque enfin
nous prenons en charge les forfaits pour
largo thérapie la psychomotricité la
psychologie qu'ils ne sont pas prises en
charge par la sécurité sociale pourquoi
il ne le dit pas assez c'est pas dans
les dents les dans les prises en charges
sécu c'est uniquement leur taux faune y
est décliné mais là nous prenons en
charge pour qu'il n'y ait justement une
égalité des chances pour les familles
quinze mille enfants bénéficiaient déjà
de ses forfaits précoce quarante mille
enfants autistes ont pu être détectées
beaucoup plus précocement et ont rejoint
les bancs d'école et c'est pour ça
qu'avec le miz l'éducation au salon
créer des classes maternelles autiste
qui sont très étayé très encadrée
justement l'intervention précoce c'est
le maître mot l'accessibilité c'est la
sphère de tous finalement c'est la
sphère de l'état évidemment c'est aussi
la sphère des collectivités c'est aussi
la sphère des entreprises il faut le
dire c'est aussi la sphère du monde
scolaire est ce que cette chaîne la
fonctionne bien aujourd'hui ce qui n'a
pas plus de plus de souplesse à trouver
parce que on rencontre parfois des
familles qui sont confrontées à des
lourdeurs administratives à des à des
difficultés sans nom et qui ne savent
pas quel saint se vouer est ce que
chaque euro est ce que chacun joue bien
son rôle et notamment les collectivités
mais là vous parlez de l'accessibilité
physique des bâtis ou l'accessibilité en
général les deux l'accessibilité
universelle voilà moi c'est ce terme que
je sais donc l'accepter pédagogique
c'est l'accepter physique des bâtis et
des transports c'est faire en sorte que
tout le monde se sente concerné vous
l'avez très justement dit sur les
collectivités locales les collectivités
nous travaillons main dans la main avec
elle nous les accompagnons justement
j'ai mis en place les ambassadeurs
d'accessibilité je vais bientôt
rencontrer justement le président de
l'association des maires de france david
lisnard pourquoi vraiment essais mais
cela parce que ça ne démarre pas assez
fort ça c'est l'accessibilité du
quotidien comment je vais aider le
commerçant à se rendre accessible pour
la participation l'accessibilité
universelle
dans l'école dans l'entreprise c'est
vraiment lent jeu de mots de mon
ministère pourquoi je suis rattaché
auprès du premier ministre pour changer
la donne dans toutes les politiques
publiques avec les collectivités avec
les employeurs avec l'école et c'est
justement comment est ce qu'on peut
améliorer dans l'esprit dans la tête des
décideurs de demain à tous les niveaux
les futurs élus les futurs dirigeants la
prise en compte du handicap qui apparaît
souvent on assoit un peu l'impression
que c'est ce c7 chose à laquelle on
pense une fois qu'on a fait tout le
reste n'est ni les handicaps comment
améliorer ça est ce que par exemple et
là les énarques ou luz où ceux qui le
remplaçant de lin sont solidement formés
à la prise en compte du handicap dans
toutes ses dimensions c'est l'enjeu
majeur c'est l'enjeu majeur je vous
rappelle que ça fait 20 ans qu'on se bat
et justement pour avoir la formation au
handicap dans les instants auprès des
enseignants en formation initiale c'est
chose faite depuis septembre donc on
voit bien que c'est dans les formations
initiales de tout un chacun qu'il faut
mettre justement cette prise en compte
du handicap donc c'est ce que l'on fait
avec les étudiants en médecine
maintenant dans tous les stages dans
leur cursus liseron des stages à faire
il faut qu'on le fasse partout dans les
architectes auprès des architectes pour
qu'ils aient cette accessibilité
universelle sur le numérique les
webmasters ne sont pas assez formés à
l'accessibilité numérique universelle
donc on est souvent en rattrapage c'est
un enjeu colossal tous concernés tous
mobilisés c'est bien le le leu tempo que
j'essaye de tenir depuis 2010 est c'est
sophie cluzel la secrète à d'état chargé
des personnes handicapées qui est notre
invité ce matin sur tv5 monde avec ouest
france nice matin et france antilles un
collaborateur de ouest-france régulier
et dessinateur bien connu chaunu va vous
poser une question à travers son dessin
c'est une tradition dans cette émission
française a dit exactement même la
ministre c'est dans votre expérience
personnelle que vous puisez l'énergie
pour améliorer la vie des personnes en
situation de handicap la question que je
pose c'est pourquoi déploie ton autant
de moyens pour construire des pistes
cyclables alors que
c'est un véritable parcours du
combattant qui attend les personnes en
situation de handicap quand elle se
déplace dans les villes
combat de tous les jours comment on fait
que l'accessibilité universelle et pensé
par tous je crois beaucoup aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques pour accès
amélioré l'accessibilité vont tenir
votre place jeudi prochain à battre est
bien chose je le salue n'avance c'est un
combat de tous le temps pensé accepté
universel vous avez tout à fait raison
pour ce que vous avez le franc encore
une question justement autour du autour
du sport on a parlé de la culture on
dort à tony estanguet sur ce plateau
dans une semaine on parlera des des jeux
paralympiques mais le sport au quotidien
est aussi sans doute beaucoup à faire
pour permettre aux personnes handicapées
de vivre pleinement leur leurs envies de
sport
et bien dans le collectif
gouvernementales que nous sommes avec
roxana maracineanu nous avons travaillé
sur un andy goode c'est-à-dire pour
pouvoir tout simplement savoir à côté de
chez moi dans une plate forme numérique
qu'est ce qui est déjà accessible mais
pas seulement l'accessibilité des bâtis
est ce que des gens formés à accueillir
un petit garçon autiste qui veut faire
du tennis au club de tennis ont créé ce
succès du très concret et puis c'est les
30 minutes de sport à l'école c'est le
sport ensemble c'est-à-dire adapté et le
sport ordinaire c'est la coopération
avec le médico social dans les écoles
c'est tout simple il faut aussi
souligner le rôle important des
associations parce que beaucoup
d'associations
les initiatives à ses fabuleuses on dans
ce domaine là exactement la une d'ouest
france françois xavier le franc vous
êtes le rédacteur en chef de ce
quotidien qui est le plus important dans
le monde francophone oui exactement et
qui organise à nantes aujourd'hui et
demain un grand rendez-vous de réflexion
sur l'alimentation c'est important
pourquoi est ce que les supermarchés
sont pleins c'est parce qu'il ya les
paysans qui travaillent et dans 5 ans
d'ici cinq ans 45% des agriculteurs
français auront cessé leur activité
l'agriculture va manquer de bras et
c'est donc un sujet que nous avons
développées aujourd'hui en une et qui
est un sujet sérieux auquel tout le
monde devrait s'intéresser de très près
et puis vous organiser à nouveau les
assises économique des outre-mer oui on
parle beaucoup des outre-mer en ce
moment
avec eux dès la question des questions
économiques extrêmement importante la
question de la lutte contre la pauvreté
mais la question du développement
économique et donc le 7 décembre
prochain mardi prochain nous organisons
un événement 100% digitale avec les
acteurs de l'ensemble des territoires
ultramarins pour réfléchir à ces
questions et l'actualité montre que ce
sont des questions urgentes avec
d'autres partenaires qu'on voit sur
l'écran merci françois xavier le franc
rédacteur en chef de l ouest france à
jeudi prochain dans un instant armelle
le goff de famine est innocent sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
en jouant mal de gorge et merci jade
inauguré l'âge présence de famine dans
cette émission merci d'être avec nous
dans un instant nous allons venir à des
questions liées toujours aux secteurs
ministériels de sophie cluzel inscrits à
d'état aux personnes handicapées qui est
notre invité ce matin mais tout de suite
denis carot qu'est directeur des
rédactions de nice-matin à une question
à vous poser en duplex de nice en
l'écoutent
bonjour sophie cluzel les femmes
handicapées sont particulièrement
exposés aux violences et
particulièrement aux violences sexuelles
c'est ce qu'a démontré une étude
effectuée récemment en nouvelles
aquitaine est-ce que ce phénomène est
suffisamment prises en compte et de
quelle manière pour et ont amélioré la
situation
bonjour monsieur carreaux vous avez
raison ça fait l'objet de tout mais
attention de toutes nos attentions avec
elisabeth moreno nous étions encore à
l'assemblée nationale avec une grosse
table ronde cette enquête est la mise en
lumière des choses que nous connaissons
sur lequel nous allons nous agissons
formation dans les établissements
médico-sociaux j'ai envoyé une
circulaire il ya deux ans très
précisément pour que l'on fasse on
vraiment conscience de ça la feuille de
route de la santé sexuelle est très
importante pour éviter justement ces
violences parce que beaucoup de femmes
n'ont pas conscience qu'elles sont
violentes et notamment les femmes
autistes avec nous travaillons donc avec
l'association des femmes autistes
francophone avec femmes pour le dire
femmes pour agir pour améliorer la
formation l'information et la prise de
conscience de ces femmes armelle le goff
avec le co vide 19 évidemment qui est
aussi présent dans l'actualité bonjour
madame la ministre on entre dans une
cinquième vague épidémique or lors des
vagues précédentes certaines
associations se sont inquiétés
concernant la prise en charge des
personnes handicapées que pouvez vous
nous dire à ce sujet les personnes
handicapées ont fait l'objet de toute
mon attention dès le 1er confinement ils
ont été prioritaires pour la reprise des
cols elles ont été prioritaires pour la
vaccination
donc moi je n'ai qu'un mot fait vraiment
attention alors appel ça c'est très
important et nous nous mettons vraiment
en ordre de marche leur dire aussi qu
elles sont toutes nos attentions puisque
nous avons tout de suite financer les
masques inclusive par exemple pour les
personnes sourdes paquet de rupture et
d'éloignement travailler aussi sur les
adaptations ce qui ont été faites pour
les personnes autistes donc voilà on a
fait faites tout bois je leur dis vous
êtes l'attention du gouvernement parce
que bien sûr il ya des vulnérabilités
plus importante des commodes ou co
morbidité importante aussi notamment
pour les personnes trisomiques pour les
personnes qui ont d'obésité donc il faut
absolument
faire cette troisième dose c'est très
important ce rappel est important il est
développé par tous en accès avec les
agences régionales de santé dans les
établissements il faut aller vers aussi
des personnes isolées et la vaccination
même pour les enfants vulnérables
justement comme le recommande la haute
autorité de santé bien sûr nous irons
dans les établissements médico sociaux
pour les enfants pour aller vers la
vaccination de ceux qui sont partie de
la liste des personnes à risque 20
minutes est partenaire de cette émission
ce matin avec sophie cluzel secrétaire
d'état chargé des personnes handicapées
un lecteur de 20 minutes jérôme orioles
qui habite strasbourg à une question
pour vous sophie cluzel on écoute
nos journaux nos ministres j'ai rempli
un dossier la maison départementale des
personnes handicapées pour faire
reconnaître un handicap le délai annoncé
pour le traitement du dossier et de
quatre mois et demi j'ai envoyé mon
dossier au 2 décembre dernier et je n'ai
toujours pas de nouvelles trouvez vous
cela normal mais assure que non je ne
trouve ça complètement anormal c'est
bien pour ça qu'avec les départements
qui sont responsables des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées on a fait un baromètre on a
travaillé j'ai remis de l'argent sur les
systèmes informatiques et on s'est fixé
comme objectif de descendre en dessous
de 4 mois pour l'ensemble des dossiers
est en dessous trois mois pour les
demandes d'allocation adulte handicapé
d'une envolée ces délais là c'est quoi
c'est très variable parce que parfois le
système informatique n'a pas été à la
hauteur parce que parfois il manque dans
les dents les
on a un problème aussi de structures de
temps médicaux pour pouvoir étudier les
dossiers notamment pour les dossiers
avec handicap si autisme mais là c'est
pas normal depuis décembre ça veut dire
que c'est presque un an donc je vous le
dit écrivez à votre président du
département nous nous pousserons nous
irons voir à strasbourg sienne
particularité sur cette maison du
handicap et ce baromètre permet vous de
mesurer les avancées des autres c'est
possible ayad c'est possible dans
certains coins de france il faut que ce
soit possible partout moi je suis en
effet la ministre des personnes partout
sur le territoire français donc nous y
veillerons ensemble à main de gauche il
ya ces lourdeurs administratives qui
pèsent sur le monde du handicap vous
mené beaucoup d'actions pour changer le
regard sur le handicap et l'inclusion
des personnes handicapées
pour autant aujourd'hui seulement 3,8
pour cent des salariés du privé sont
porteurs de handicap pourquoi pourquoi
ce chiffre si faible alors c'est un
quota de 6% qui date depuis 30 ans bien
parce que il faut d'abord faire monter
en qualifications les personnes
handicapées il faut accompagner les
entreprises moi je dis qu'aucun
employeur malveillants ils sont souvent
démunis c'est pour ça qu'on a mis dans
une prime des dalles emploie 4000 euros
pour tous et d'aidé signé là depuis
trois mois on est à vingt six mille
contrats 60% cdi donc ce coup de pouce
il est aussi producteur de résultats le
dispositif du job coaching l'information
le duo dès qu'on a fait la semaine
dernière avec trente mille offres de
diaw voilà c'est tout ça qui peut
changer la donne et surtout embarqué
avec le manifeste inclusion
l'implication des dirigeants c'est comme
ça qu'on y arrivera plus vite et plus
fort voilà avec clément d'houdain qu'à
25 ans a passé beaucoup d'entretien sans
trouver de job il a une question à vous
poser
bonjour je m'appelle le lendemain j'ai
25 ans je suis à la recherche d'un
emploi j'ai envoyé plus de 100
candidatures avec plusieurs entretiens
sans qu'une réponse positif ma question
pour madame
istres est ce qu'à l'avenir ils vont
avoir plus de postes réservés qu'aux
personnes handicapées
alors nous travaillons justement pour
que les personnes handicapées puissent
accéder comme tout un chacun en monde du
travail ce que je dis à clément deux
choses d'abord il faut savoir parler de
son handicap de ses besoins spécifiques
parce que les employeurs cherchent aussi
des personnes handicapées d'état
grecques sont pliés mieux l'eau il
expliquait déjà est ce qu'il faut le
mettre sur son cv ben je dis oui parce
que c'est toute la libération de la
parole qu'on est en train de travailler
moi les personnes handicapées les
employeurs me disent on voudrait bien
mais on trouve pas de talent donc jeudi
à clément ne restez pas tout seul
faites-vous accompagner par justement
les dispositifs d'emploi accompagnés
qu'on met pour peut-être vous aider à
pousser mieux les portes et je suis sûr
vous allez arriver à trouver parce que
vous avez des talents il faut juste les
maîtres peut-être mieux en
accompagnement dans les dents les
entretiens de recrutement ce qui est
compliqué non et c'est comme ça qu'on y
arrivera ensemble armelle le goff je
crois qu'on a une question aussi sur
l'entrepreneuriat pour les personnes
handicapées qui peut être aussi un
recours pour entrer sur le marché du
travail intégrer le marché du travail
c'est très important parce que ça peut
permettre aussi de choisir son rythme
selon son handicap et donc nous
soutenons bien sûr à chaque entrepreneur
mais pas que 1 qu'ils et nous
travaillons aussi pour l'heure améliorer
l'accès au crédit l'accès aux assurances
qui est un vrai le blocage et je pense
que c'est tout à fait un levier
important d'accéder au marché du travail
comme peut-être aussi l'intérim on
développe des entreprises adaptées de
travail intérimaire c'est aussi une
façon de pouvoir rentrer dans
l'entreprise ou dans le monde du travail
morgane legrand qui est malvoyante
animatrice d'une émission de télévision
qui s'appelle avec les yeux de morgan /
tv 78 notre partenaire co producteur la
chaîne des yvelines dirigé par thiery
barbedette qui d'ailleurs sur le plateau
avec tout à une question à vous poser
madame le ministre on écoute
j'ai une question à vous adresser
aujourd'hui le taux de chômage des
personnes en situation de handicap est
toujours plus élevé que celui des
valides et ce en dépit de plusieurs
initiatives alors l'entrepreneuriat et
tin une solution à prendre en
considération pour redistribuer les
cartes et surtout est-ce qu'il ya des
aides du soutien us bien sûr qu'il ya
des aides et des soutiens mai qu'il faut
c'est donner l'information c'est ça qui
nous manque un dans notre pays c'est
l'accès à l'information c'est pour ça
qu'on fait une plateforme roczen avec
tout ce qui existe aujourd'hui de moyens
sur internet et bien sûr mais c'est que
c'est encore éparpillés c'est pour ça
qu'on fait une seule porte d'entrée avec
les entreprises s'engagent on aura une
plateforme numérique justement pour
pouvoir donner tout c'est tout c'est
tout c'est toutes ces aides il faut
qu'on cartographie au plus près des
bassins d'emploi delà où vivent les
personnes donc oui mangane
l'entrepreneuriat pour les personnes
handicapées est un vrai levier d'accéder
au marché du travail et on va vous
accompagner pour le développer
rapprochez vous de l'association
achoppent entrepreneur un jugement
contre h hop entrepreneur jeu qui
accompagnant justement tous ces stars
torpeur handicapées qui veulent qu'ils
veulent accéder à l'entrepreneuriat
l'inclusion c'est aussi considérer les
personnes handicapées comme des
individus à part entière alors pourquoi
la hache nettel toujours pas d conjugue
alizés comme le demandent beaucoup
d'associations et beaucoup d'acteurs du
monde du handicap
alors oui c'est un sujet qui est porté
par les associations se lâche donc
l'allocation adulte handicapé qui a été
réhaussée 1 900 euros avec 2 milliards
d'investissements sur ce quinquennat et
suit les mêmes règles que tous les
minima sociaux c'est à dire que la
solidarité familiale et c'est à dire
qu'on prend en compte le couple les
revenus du foyer
pour calculer la location et lé
différentiel aussi selon les revenus du
travail donc moi j'entends cette
revendication des associations j'ai
entendu tout de suite en relevant le
plafond parce qu'en effet nous avons
changé le mode de calcul et la cent
vingt mille personnes en couple vont
avoir tout de suite dès le 1er janvier
une amélioration de la hache quand ils
sont en cours par rapport à leurs
besoins mais moi je dis justement ce
sont des citoyens à part entière donc
posons nous les questions sur tous les
minima sociaux aussi bien bien sûr le
rsa la hache et puis là pas qu'ils sont
là pour les personnes âgées qui sont
calculées de la même façon c'est un vrai
sujet de société est-ce qu on
individualise nos minima sociaux et à ce
moment là comment on va les financer
donc c'est je pense que c'est
sociétalement c'est un sujet à porter
pour les années à venir de façon
importante et je rappelle que
l'allocation adulte handicapé existe
mais c'est aussi la prestation de
compensation du handicap qui elle est
individualisé selon les besoins de la
personne la technique du maine aide
financière je voudrais maintenant
aborder la question des aidants qui sont
nombreux à venir en aide un conjoint un
parent à un enfant qui est porteur de
handicap
pourquoi et enfin et c'est ce qu'ils
demandent aujourd'hui de plus en plus
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne considère pas
cela comme une activité à part entière
parce que on sait que c'est extrêmement
prenant que ça peut demander du temps
accompagnés à son enfant chez le médecin
ça prend du temps sur son temps de
travail aussi alors on a mis le congé
proches aidants en place et merci de me
donner l'occasion d'en refaire la
promotion parce qu'il n'est pas assez
connu donc ces trois mois de bon tirage
qu'on peut prendre dans sa vie
professionnelle pour concilier sa vie
personnelle et sa vie professionnelle
parce que en effet qu'est ce qu'on
risque en risque du burn out on cache
ont fait un arrêt maladie non là
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus
confortable dans le dialogue avec son
employeur c'est rémunérés au niveau du
smic ont l'art et essai de au 1er
janvier c'est pas assez connue donc
merci de m'en faire la promotion vous
pouvez dialoguer avec votre employeur et
l'asthme et aidants font l'objet de
toutes nos attentions 8 millions des
danses et des piliers de la société faut
qu'on les accompagne autre sujet
d'accompagnement les aes h ils sont au
nombre de 125 1000 dons de la même façon
le statut a été très utile valorisé au
message qui viennent en aide aux enfants
magnan d'élèves en situation de handicap
qui viennent en aide aux enfants qui
sont en situation de handicap dans les
écoles
enfin ils ont toujours des
revendications concernant leur statut
qu'il juge trop précaire trop fragile
comment faire en sorte que ce maillon
essentiel de l'école de l'inclure de
l'inclusion se sentent totalement
valoriser et à sa place d'abord je
voudrais leur dire les saluer sur le
travail qu'ils font il ya eu 35 % de
plus d'accompagnement des élèves en
situation de handicap depuis 2017 ils
sont tous un statut éducation nationale
quand nous sommes arrivés il y avait 60
% contrats aidés donc ça s'améliore
j'entends que ça va pas assez vite ils
font l'objet du dialogue social au sein
du ministère de l'éducation nationale il
faut qu'on travaille à améliorer leur
formation des formations conjointes avec
les enseignants mais aussi avec le
médico social certains deviennent un
espace ressources sont plus payés parce
qu'il ya plus de temps horaire en fait
la problématique elle est là mais je
voudrais dire vraiment que nous
travaillons avec eux sur leur formation
sur l'amélioration de leur temps de
travail qui le le lien majeur et puis
aussi on a vraiment besoin de ces
personnels qui sont extrêmement
performants auprès des élèves en
situation d'handicap et puis armelle le
goff 20 minutes à consacrer un hors
série sur le handicap ce sont des
opérations que vous allez régulièrement
mené tous les ans effectivement oui on
et puis on vous ayez vous est interviewé
dans dans ce numéro qui des signes
d'amélioration c'est positif ce titre
oui c'est positif après il ya aussi on
en parlait tout à l'heure sur les
violences sexuelles des choses qui ne
qui n'ont pas encore avancé beaucoup
dans le monde dehors du handicap on se
demande quand même pourquoi le handicap
n'a pas fait son mythe ou parce qu'on
sait que c'est quand même un lieu de
violence sexuelle potentiellement ben ça
c'est les associations qui doivent le
porter et c'est donc moi je suis aux
côtés des associations je travaille avec
elle on a mis des groupes de travail
associations de femmes et associations
spécialistes du handicap pour justement
accompagner les femmes qui veulent
sortir de cette emprise très important
et il ya encore du travail bien sûr on a
formé à l'as recueil de la parole avec
le ministère de l'intérieur le ministère
de la justice mais voilà il ya encore du
temps cette prise de conscience il faut
qu'elle a kel ce qu'elle est merci à la
rive merci merci nous allons continuer
avec vous dans un vaste champ merci
armelle le goff et revenez vite sur ce
plateau vous êtes là je veux saluer
l'implication de 20 minutes un vraiment
sociation salut l'application et 20
minutes et ont remercié armelle le goff
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
notre partenaire pour cette émission
dans un instant les questions
internationales l'acipa garcia sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
bonjour sylvia garcia vous êtes
journaliste à tv5monde vous présenter le
64 minutes qui s est cher ici même et
vous avez des questions à poser à sophie
cluzel évidemment c'est les nations
unies oui nous ont interpellé les
nations unies auditionné la france dans
ses conclusions le nu invite la france à
se mettre en conformité avec la
convention internationale des droits des
personnes handicapées le pays des droits
de l'homme on prend un petit peu pour
son grade alors je pense que nous avons
joué trois auditions un 3-3 temps
d'audition non elle n'a pas attendu à
l'onu pour avancer notamment la grande
campagne nationale de sensibilisation du
handicap qui était programmé il ya deux
ans mais avec la crise sanitaire on a dû
la retarder c'était un des sujets
qu'elle pointe et la participation des
personnes eh bien j'ai fait une grande
rénovation du conseil national
consultatif des personnes handicapées
pour qui une meilleure représentation
des personnes après l'onu je pense n'a
pas tout entendu aussi un toutes les
réponses qu'on a pu faire la danse vous
à féliciter a vu les progrès mais j'ai
dit mais quand même et c'est un peu ce
que l'onu a pointé du doigt ça ne va pas
assez vite alors c'est bien pour ça que
le président de la république l'a
développée comme grande cause un
priorités du quinquennat est à rattacher
mon secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre c'est comme ça qu'on change la
donne dans toutes les politiques de
droit commun donc c'est beaucoup plus
transformateurs que d'avoir une grande
loi handicap cluzel peut-être au
détriment de la de la connaissance même
du handicap mais c'est comme ça qu'on
change la donne la loi sur le travail la
loi sur l'école c'est comme ça qu'on va
en profondeur changer nos minables roche
un petit peu trop médical et pas assez
centré sur les droits de l'homme voilà
ce que nous dit l'onu voulait bien
portants le fait d'être attaché auprès
du premier ministre nous avons remis les
personnes handicapées majeur sous leur
droit de vote c'était attendu depuis 30
ans c'est une grande avancée dont il
faut qu'elles soient éligibles aussi et
l'achever appel je dire à toutes les
instances politiques encouragent et
voilà l'implication des personnes
handicapées et puis nous travaillons
aussi sur le choix de vie c'est ça qui
m'apporte énormément c'est à dire
démultiplier les choix de vie notamment
dans l'habitat inclusif qu'on a
développés avant c'était tout collectif
tout seul là maintenant on peut avoir un
projet de vie partagée a aussi prendre
en compte ceux qui ont le besoin les
plus spécifiques comme les
polyhandicapés et autistes sévère donc
voilà je pense que mon a avancé qu'on
n'aille pas assez vite je l'entends mais
on travaille ardemment avec les
personnes elles-mêmes et puis sylvia
garcia il y à des pays hors d'europe où
ça se passe beaucoup mieux alors les des
pays en europe en tout cas vers lesquels
les handicapés en france se tourne c'est
le cas de la belgique notamment le
voisin à qui se trouvait au nord 8000
personnes dont 1500 enfants ont trouvé
refuge dans des en belgique dans des
institutions malgré plusieurs scandales
de maltraitance les départs n'ont cessé
d'augmenter ces dernières années en 2019
je passais naît de la pandémie mais en
2010 9 550 enfants et adultes partie
faute d'avoir trouvé une place en france
est ce que l'état français se défausse
encore aujourd'hui on veut absolument
verra
et on a mis un moratoire pour les
enfants plus aucun enfant qui ne le
souhaitent pas enfin parents qui ne le
souhaitent pas large en belgique non ça
c'était il ya 2016 pour les enfants et
les adultes chez mia moratoire en
février de l'année dernière pour se
doper cela ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que ce sont des établissements
spécialisés qui peut être ont plus de
facilité d'abord travaillé 365 jours
j'ai 90 millions de budget sanctuariser
pour sortir les places beaucoup plus
vite au plus près des territoires
combien de places on parle de quelque
1100 places qui ont déjà été créés nous
avons aussi fermé deux établissements
avec mon homologue wallonne avec qui je
travaille très bien qu'il ya aussi cette
prise de conscience parce qu'il y avait
de la maltraitance nous avons
immédiatement rapatriés plus de 75
adultes et on a trouvé des solutions
celle affaire de tous j'ai besoin des
collectivités territoriales bien sûr
départementale puisque sur les adultes
ils sont en responsabilité sur le
logement donc c'est un travail vraiment
sur mesure les les budgets sont là il
faut qu'on aille plus vite et j'ai
besoin des organismes gestionnaires 1
qui sont financés pour 14 milliards par
la france en france pour sortir les
places encore plus vite inc et son
fameux millefeuille
administrative dont on parle beaucoup
fermi perturbe votre politique et votre
volonté il est construit donc moi tout
l'état peu beaucoup mais seul je n'y
arriverai pas si les départements
justement ce à s'impliquer c'est le cas
j'ai des laboratoires vraiment et je
tiens à saluer par exemple le résident
d'un appartement où l'un des régions pas
des zones en merco soit d où les
départements qui sont aussi en chef de
file des politiques de solidarité à
travers avec lesquels j'ai énormément de
travail en construction et je salue
l'association des départements de france
qui avec le président sauvadet qui a qui
s'est réinscrit dans la même mouvance
que j'avais signé avec le président
bussereau donc l'implication aller réel
pour qu'on aille plus vite plus vite et
puis surtout va être concret admettons
je vis le parent d'un enfant autiste
aujourd'hui on me dit bas la belgique ne
restait plus tôt en france vous parler
de la création de 1800 places il ya
quarante cinq mille personnes en attente
donc je sais pas d'où sort chaud s'il
faut excuser malheur humain dit non non
non il n'y a pas de yap à 45000
personnes en attendant une idée aux
narines avec combien de navires en
attente de place on a huit mille
personnes qui sont ce qu'on appelle en
amendement creton dans les et 6000
personnes en amendement creton c'est à
dire qu'ils ont des passes du linge les
vallotton l'acteur s'était beaucoup
impliqué ac qui s'est beaucoup impliqué
exactement est donc ça ça c'est une
vraie réalité et puis après on ne veut
laisser personne au bord du chemin donc
ils sont ils sont prises en charge mais
pas dans l'idéal de la solution c'est
pour ça que je développe la
inclusive c'est pour ça que je développe
le job coaching c'est pour ça que nous
développons les unités résidentielles
pour autistes sévère mais ça ça veut
dire qu'il faut sortir des conseils ou
dernière vaut aujourd'hui comme une
heure et n'était pas seul je redis 1 le
numéro date d'accompagnement le 0 800
363 160 les maisons départementales des
personnes handicapées sont là pour
travailler avec vous c'est la sphère de
tous je veux dire une seule association
ne s'en sortira pas on l'a bien vu
pendant le confinement ils ont fait des
choses extraordinaires c'est pour ça que
je travaille avec elle sur cette méthode
différente de se dire que ben peut être
revu là il ya une place d'un tel
établissement spécialisé on va renforcer
l'équipe pour pouvoir accueillir et puis
surtout il faut que dans le droit commun
grâce à l'habitat inclusif on trouve des
solutions de logement accompagner autant
que de besoin
cette journée mondiale
des personnes handicapées c'est
important c'est important c'est une
journée qui va nous permettre de faire
des gestes mémorielle important puisque
c'est demain je rappelle c'est demain
nous aurons un geste très important pour
moi que l'on que l'on fait depuis 2010
est avec charles gardou déposer une
gerbe sur la plaque dans le sur le
parvis des droits de l'homme je rappelle
que quarante cinq mille personnes
handicapées notamment psychique ont été
abandonnées dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques
alors de l'occupation donc là c'est un
geste fort on aura
la mise en place de la statue l'homme
qui roulent en face de l'homme qui
marche à l'unesco et je trouve que c'est
un très beau très beau symbole de
rapprocher ces mondes et puis voilà on à
la campagne nationale de sensibilisation
du handicap il faut vraiment si la
journée de la citoyenneté des personnes
handicapées en tout cas merci de me
donner l'occasion de le rappeler est de
dire que je comprends bien qui a encore
du chemin et que je serai aux côtés des
personnes handicapées quoi qu'il arrive
pour avancer encore plus vite plus fort
que les un enfant du cluzel secrétaire
d'état chargé des personnes handicapées
merci s'il y avait un cias et à des
questions un peu plus politique car vous
êtes aussi une femme politique on l'a
bien vu aux dernières régionales vous
êtes effacé devant renaud muselier le
candidat donc qui est devenu président
de la région sud et guy l'amérique avis
qu'est le directeur des rédactions de la
provence à une question à vous poser en
l'écoutent oui bonjour à tous bonjour
sophie cluzel renaud muselier a annoncé
qu'il quittait les républicains il y a
quelques jours vous comprenez cette
décision et est ce que ça ne va pas
déstabiliser totalement l'échiquier
politique en région provence alpes côte
d'azur
je pense que l'échiquier il a déjà bougé
on va prendre en provence alpes côte
d'azur non je tiens à saluer cette
décision de renaud muselier je l'invite
à ajustements à venir rejoindre
ensemble citoyens avec par exemple parti
horizon puisque christian estrosi l'a
annoncé vous avez des conversations avec
lui invitant nombre à ces derniers temps
j'ai des conversations avec mes
colistiers qui ont qui ont intégré
justement là la liste de la région et
qui font un travail remarquable et tout
se passe très bien donc je dire que ce
travail de coopération de collaboration
c'est une réalité sur le terrain au
service des habitants de la région
provence alpes côte d'azur donc est-ce
que vous avait des ambitions politiques
dans cette région vous avez été élu est
ce que vous voulez continuer la
politique après j'allais dire votre
votre mission un ministériel
particulière au service des personnes
handicapées moi je suis là depuis 2010
est dans ce gouvernement j'ai des feux
de route traîtres et des chantiers de
fond que je souhaite vraiment mener
jusqu'au bout donc on est vraiment dans
l'action là dans l'exécution j'ai une
somme de déplacement colossal j'espère
pouvoir aller aux antilles très
prochainement j'étais obligée d'annuler
deux fois trois fois et je salue
vraiment les ultramarins qui se fond qui
sont nos partenaires de france en
exactement donc voilà énormément de
travail on aura la présidence française
de l'union européenne va avoir une très
grosse journée à préparer avec tous mes
homologues européens le 9 mars donc avec
des sujets qui sont l'emploi la
citoyenneté les avancées sont lodsys la
politique locale ou alors à dire aux et
le terme politicienne extra vous paraît
très éloigné de ce que vous avez à faire
dans les années qui viennent d'où la
région reste quand même la région
je me suis dépassée je me suis effacé
voilà sur la région provence alpes côte
d'azur je salue tous les tous les tous
les habitants mais non vous considérez
vous êtes effacé ne je me suis je pense
que je me suis appliqué moi même ce que
je prône c'est à dire le dépassement de
soi au service justement de du
rassemblement c'est ce qui a été fait
puisque forcément maintenant nous avons
18 conseillers régionaux de la majorité
présidentielle sur cette liste tout le
monde travaille très bien ensemble au
service de la politique locale et c'est
ça le plus important des habitants est
ce que votre département ministériel
fait l'objet d'une forme d'unanimité ah
oui je pense que sincèrement pas
simplement au sein du gouvernement je
pensais dillon dans le paysage politique
est ce que est ce que le handicap est
assez fédérateur de l'ensemble dé toute
façon moi je travaille avec nous
servions des rares choses qu'il est
encore sans la bible dit non par exemple
égalité femmes-hommes aussi est très
fédérateur non il ya beaucoup de sujets
gouvernementaux qui sont fédérateurs sur
la façon dont on peut le porter en
territoire
moi je travaille avec tous les élus
locaux de tous bords qu'ils soient
maires de présent département président
de région puisque de toute façon encore
une fois sur ce sujet là c'est la
responsabilité populationnelle
collective qui fonctionnera et puis au
sein du gouvernement non je pense que
nous avons cinq comité interministériel
du handicap sous l'égide du premier
ministre depuis 2017 et tout le monde a
une feuille de route extrêmement précise
et pas largement participé par exemple
audio des c'est pas que symbolique c'est
vraiment aussi de l'action merci
beaucoup sophie cluzel secrétaire d'état
chargé des personnes handicapées d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin sur tv5 monde
en direct la veille de cette journée
internationale des personnes handicapées
et l'avait du téléthon c'est important
aussi il faudra donner pour aider merci
beaucoup la semaine prochaine donc tony
estanguet président de paris à 2024 et
johan djourou remis les jours 1000 jours
mais il joue en mille jours avant les
jeux olympiques car s'il vient merci et
au revoir à tous les programmes continus
sur tv5
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]